So today, I'm going to
use my imagination and write about myself in 10 years.
[Music] I
can't imagine it at all. I
looked at Mr. Nishimura and wrote about myself in 10 years.
[Music] I
grew up and got Mass O Dark Dancer.  It
's me. I'm the chosen one. Why am
I next to you?
It's because I want to be with you forever. It'll be
really lonely if you leave me.
Takada-
kun, how many people is this? That's Nishimura-san's
ectoplasm. Mine.
Nishimura-san's ectoplasm. Me.  It's
10 years after Ectoplasm, so if you ca
n't do this much, your Shinigami skills will
probably have improved, so it's not that
cute.
Nishimura-san is always too
cute. If you don't do something like this, it won't be
cool. I'm
sorry. I wish I could have drawn a cooler picture.
[Music] I
always say you're too cute